tu perds ton bébé deux jours après tu te
roule dans le sable par terre en tenant
tessin
vous savez combien vous rapporte encore
aller 10 ans chaque mois vas-y francky
c'est bon puisque chaque fois que ça
passe à la radio on est sympa que ça
blesse chez moi quand je vois la scène
cette touche gros à la sacem tous les
faits et à la saisie d'un semestriels
non mais après tout les trois mois c'est
une petite somme les bonnes années tous
les sommets jeu touché un million
d'euros
marc est alors attendez j'ai fait à une
chanson aussi
millions d'euros mais tous les sinois je
ferai de l'ablation ça ne passe pas
qu'en france mène à bon prix non c'est
impossible j'étais premiers au
hit-parade à colomby banon ni moi même
j'étais un peu de poésie de moi aussi
j'ai des petits accusé d'avoir fait caca
son oreiller voilà et et ils ont même
analysé le petit est charmant et ils ont
considéré en vue la taille ça ne pouvait
pas être un chien
c'est pas là c'était voilà ça faisait
pas d'un chien alors comment te
différencier la merde d'un chien que
d'un maire de la laddh
j'ai vu de la mer de 12 permanents s'y
voit pas faire la même crainte que toi
mais un doberman
ça serait ok c'est le sien ça sent
mistakes et loyauté et parenthèse vous
savez qu'on a appris bout c'est pourquoi
le caca et odorant
vous allez retomber dans un habit
téléspectateurs
c'est un fou est vrai en fait c'est le
corps humain qui met volontairement une
mauvaise odeur et pourquoi pas tenter
pour le mans j'ai fait ça et cette
semaine pour la première fois il ya la
third en demeure qui est venu à la barre
pour témoigner de violences physiques
auxquels elle a assisté c'est la
première fois que quelqu'un corroborent
les allemands soit à l'heure avec les
soldes et des photos je crois oui on a
une photo de leur lune de miel sur
lequel on voit que le visage de l'acteur
est assez tuméfié et elle a accusé
l'avocate génitales a fourni des fausses
photos ou photoshop ça va durer deux ou
parce que oui si claire belluteau photo
j'apprends deux jours mabouls a passé au
scanner tamedia oui bien sûr et puis de
toute façon là on est au coeur du
problème entre les deux c'est à dire que
l'un comme l'autre s'accusent
mutuellement de mentir sur la violence
physique dont ils ont il se serait rendu
coupable l'un comme l'autre et johnny a
par exemple dit pendant le procès johnny
depp qu'elle lui avait coupé le doigt
avec une bouteille de vodka et des
cicatrices qui lie la
femme devraient s'y retrouver le bout
des doigts d'un blabla n'ont même pas en
trouver quelqu'un du doigt c'est ça
c'est ça alors là le procès il qu'ils
vont empirer cette semaine je crois
globalement on pense que denis devra
gagner commentait la partie oui oui
parce qu'il est en fête ce soir que ce
procès est télévisé on peut dire parce
qu'il est diffusé sur plusieurs
plateformes a pas toutes les maisons
mais il est repris aussi sur sur twitch
et sur d'autres plateformes qui récupère
les images donc en fait les américains
mais le monde entier assiste au procès
est en fait la guerre de l'image est en
train d'être gagnée par johnny des abris
qui lui n'est pas théâtrale comme amber
a à chaque audience il reste
relativement sobre et en plus ça
contraste avec le johnny depp ya deux ou
trois ans qu'était à émacié amaigri et
avait l'air malade là aujourd'hui
s'exprime plutôt bien ses avocats ont
débit ils ont des images la montrant
avec d'autres hommes ils ont des
enregistrements audio où elle se
félicite de l'avoir frappé donc en fait
tout l'argumentaire de damber tombe à
l'eau d'autant plus qu'elle s'était
engagé lors du premier procès ya deux
ans à l'inversé beaucoup d'argent à des
oeuvres elle ne l'a pas fait c'est
surtout à laver ou plan du premier
procès elle avait accepté une
transaction à 7 millions $ afin que ça
s'arrête mais elle a menti sous serment
en disant qu'elle allait donner une
grande partie de cette somme alors en
amérique le par jour je vous le dis
c'est alors oui elle a perdu 7 à
des révélations absolument incroyable
sur sa sécurité à l'époque était sous la
tutelle ne sont pas pas il y avait alors
il y aurait eu des caméras même même
dans sa chambre au moins elle faisait
des cracks oui et c'est son père qui
écoutait en plus donc son père écoutait
sa propre fille faire crac-crac c'était
risqué ça lui étaient envoyés vous
imaginez alors à laver pourquoi florian
il a mille des caméras dans sa chambre
parce que ça faisait partie enfin en
tout cas selon lui et selon la société
qu'il avait mandaté pour le faire de la
tutelle dont étaient prisonnières
britney spears pendant toutes ces années
et en gros son téléphone tous ces coups
de fil divers et variés sont internet et
sa maison était flic et du début jusqu'à
la fin et il faut rappeler quand même
que le père qui n'a jamais suivi la
carrière de britney spears touché 130000
euros par an + des royalties sur les sur
sur les disques continuer de la rance
mais compte tenu des revenus de briser
pas nous presser c'est pas une part
importante à la brasse et des dizaines
voire des centaines de millions de
dollars certes sauf qu'elle n'a jamais
demandé à être sous la tutelle afrique
et faire l'état d'ailleurs s'en est
emparé pour briser cette tutelle parce
qu'il y avait on va pas revenir sur
toute l'histoire mais tout ça était à la
limite de la légalité est relativement
scandaleux c'est qu'elle était carrément
espionner ouais elle était je veux dire
quand elle avait des rapports sexuels si
on a bien lu ce qu'on a lu cette semaine
son père et enfin j'espère pas son père
dans tout cas potentiellement oui sont
tombés ce dès surtout c'est illégal
s'est lui dit que elle elle consentait
mais ça veut dire que même les met ses
discussions avec son avocat concernant
la tutelle et concernant le conflit est
complet il les écoute est donc c'est
tout bonnement scandaleux bien sûr un
peu inquiet pour la personne
depuis on n'avait
pas mettre une photo sur instagram
on à poil non mais même lycée mais c'est
un ensemble de choses et oui mais
comment on peut juger de son état
psychologique
entre quatre photos à poil et une
tutelle il ya quand même un
peu de mesures
même on le voit elle semblait pas tu
perds ton bébé ce qui était déjà je
pense un pour moi très dangereux pour
elle de mener cette grossesse à terme tu
perds ton db deux jours après tu te
roule dans le sac par terre en tenant
tessin tu vois bien qu'à un moment s'est
fait des gestes ne me démontre pas
qu'elle est totalement équilibrée